Now, you're a director.
I mean, this one that I saw--
I mean, if you do one,
are you still considered--
-BILL MAHER: Yeah.
-(CHUCKLES)
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
There may...
may not be repeat business,
-but certainly--
-RAY ROMANO: Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
No, I think there will be.
I mean, I enjoyed it a lot
and it's funny, you know,
it's about this Italian family,
but, like, in the sitcom,
you didn't play up
the Italian part all that much.
-This family--
-RAY: Yeah.
They're--
I mean, dinner at noon,
-what the fuck is that?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
-Is that your real--
I think they started
intermittent fasting,
-the Italians, you know 'cause--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
What is that
dinner at noon thing
and is that
what your family was,
-your real family?
-Well, here's the thing.
The family that I wrote
the movie about,
is the one I married into.
I married into that family.
I'm Italian,
I grew up in New York.
-BILL: I see.
-My parents are from this--
Were born here though,
but my wife's parents
came right over on the boat,
and didn't speak English.
And that's the universe
I wanted to write about.
And yes, on Sunday,
dinner was around noon.
Yes, that's true. It's a--
Listen it sounds like a cliché
and some of the characters
we thought,
are we stereotyping too much,
but it was--
When I started dating my wife,
I know this is gonna sound
like a stereotype.
Like, week two,
I called her house up
and I said,
"Is Anna home? It's Ray."
And her mother spoke
broken English
and she said,
"No, you know, no home."
And I said, "You just tell her
that Ray called."
And she goes,
"Okay, you hungry?"
-On the phone.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
-RAY: I know, it sounds...
it sounds like it,
but on the phone
she wanted to know
if I was hungry.
So, that's what-- I wrote...
I wrote about what I knew
and I've known that for 30--
-I've been married 35 years, so.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES)
So, that's a mock clap.
No, no. It's just odd to me
that two people
who are, like,
around the same age, 40.
-RAY: Yeah.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Who? You and me?
-Yeah, of course.
Who, like, had very similar
East Coast upbringings.
I mean, I... of course,
at this neighborhood,
a lot of Italian people,
and I didn't really see them
that much
in the neighborhood at school.
I was a delivery boy
for the local liquor
and drug store,
there's like
three stores in town.
-RAY: Right.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And I delivered for two of them
and I would--
So, I would see Italians
in their natural habitat--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
(CHUCKLES)
My first girlfriend was Italian.
-RAY: Yeah, you grew up in...
-BILL: New Jersey.
-Jersey, right? Yeah.
-BILL: Bergen County,
New Jersey.
-Yeah.
-RAY: Yeah.
No, I mean, look. I used to--
BILL: But how did we become
so different
with such similar age
and background--
Well, we're the same
in some ways, right?
-Comic.
-We still like to perform,
-and stand up.
-Yes.
You're smarter,
you're much smarter.
-No. No.
-RAY: No, you are.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-RAY: (CHUCKLES) I know.
Well, we'll see who richer
and then we'll find out
who's smarter.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
I think I win that,
I'm not sure.
I know, I think you probably do.
I'm pretty sure you do.
But neither one of us
are complaining.
-I don't think
-BILL: No, no, no.
I think it's a testament to you
that a guy like me
watches your show every week
because you--
Of course, you have
the intelligent audience,
but you cross over.
-You have the dumb audience too.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)